let's just go straight to moscow now and
our correspondent diana magnay is
outside the court where alexei
uh navalny has just been sentenced and
uh diana just bring us up to date
he has been found guilty of violating
his
suspended sentence which was a three and
a half year suspended sentence so the
judge said
that that should be converted into a
jail term
but because he served just under 11
months
house arrest already then that means
that he will be going to jail to a penal
colony
a corrective penal colony for two years
and eight months that was the decision
of the court after a long day
in court when navalny himself seemed
clearly extremely frustrated by the
legal minutiae uh that he was being hit
with
by the prosecution uh he was sarcastic
he accused them of being essentially
muppets
of the state uh and it was very touching
when he came back into court for the
final verdict
uh he drew a heart on the glass of his
cage to his wife
uh julia she took off her mask to smile
to him
and the sort of contact between the two
was really visible but just as
uh the ruling was handed down as we all
filed out at the courtroom you could see
the disappointment in her face of course
this is the first time actually that um
alexei navalny
well not the first time that he's been
sentenced to a jail term but in the past
those jail terms have been overturned on
appeal
but the climate is very different now
uh but his lawyer has said that he will
appeal that ruling
but if you look at the flavor on the
streets and the
the vehement reaction from the kremlin
and the authorities
uh i would very much doubt given this
was clearly a political decision
that uh that this ruling is overturned
the navalny team has already called for
his supporters to go
to a square managed very very close to
the kremlin
we've already seen pictures of riot
police around red square having sealed
off a large part
of the area around the kremlin there are
also riot police out in full force
in saint petersburg and as you can see
they're here in the courtroom
outside the courtroom where i am and
have been maintaining a very very strong
presence all day
the few people who did come out to
demonstrate in the vicinity they didn't
get very close
to the courtroom uh many of them were
detained
350 or more before the verdict was even
handed down
but navalny himself in a very very
rousing speech
where he accused uh the little thieving
man in the bunker as he called vladimir
putin once again
of having been behind his poisoning of
having um
uh uh embarrassed him by uh of having
used the fsb russia's domestic
intelligence agency
to try and kill him and he also called
once again on the people of russia
not to use his uh case
um as something to to to then find
to fear that that this was from the
authorities a mark of weakness
rather than anything else and that they
should remember that this is their
country
that they have rights uh and that they
should fight for them so a very rousing
speech from alexander and i think he
knew
that the sentence he would get was this
one
but as i said he is going to jail unless
his appeal
manages to overturn that ruling for two
years and eight months
okay diana thank you very much indeed
and just to say that the uk government
has called for the immediate and
unconditional release
of alexei navalny and
also of all the peaceful protesters and
journalists arrested over the last two
weeks that's from the
government here